the spread of it that we could reward
our
our workers who risked their lives to
save lives and now might be losing their
jobs
and that we can put money in the pockets
of the american people
so i'm very very proud of the fact that
tonight
relatively early we are able to say
uh that we have held the house it is uh
something quite spectacular because the
people
who helped us win were the people who
have been affected by
it thousands of those who have been
diagnosed or members of their family
diagnosed with a pre-existing condition
have spoken out have told their stories
and that was the most compelling
argument of all
so again that was our purpose
uh we have succeeded in that uh now we
have to win the white house and we're
well on our way to doing that but again
oh just we're speaking to our friends in
virginia uh over two million votes have
not been
counted in virginia yet so we're waiting
to see
what that brings in and what that means
uh for the presidential race
but i'm here just to sing the praises of
our house
democrats and our candidates not just in
terms of numbers
it's not just about the quantity it's
about the quality of leadership
that they provide for our country it's
about the fact that they
are there in the congress we are all
there
for the people and to have a strategic
plan
uh to be successful uh to retain
our control to hold the house actually
is how we say it
uh we couldn't be better served than but
our chair
uh sherry bustos uh in all of the uh
pillars of winning an election whether
it was mobilization the grassroots level
even virtually she has succeeded whether
it's about messaging in a very
disciplined way
she has succeeded in about amassing the
financial resources the money
the third m uh she has broken all
records
and uh and through it all she retained
and commanded the respect
of the house members and the competence
of all of our candidates
so with that i want to acknowledge again
uh chair
sherry bustos of illinois madam chair
i yield to you with an honor thank you
all right speaker pelosi thank you so
much for your kind words
and obviously your leadership of this
caucus you've been absolutely amazing
i'm joining you tonight from moline
illinois which is my hometown
uh moline is kind of the center of
america
it's uh you know people here they they
take that literally
and they work hard and look after each
other it's around places like this that
if your neighbor falls ill you offer to
bring over a meal to them
or you offer to look after their kids it
was in
2018 that democrats won back the house
by reaching out to people in towns
like moline by listening to them
and here's what people in those towns
the center of america told us
what we took into the 2020 elections and
that's
that they want a government that works
for them they want more progress
and less partisanship they want an end
to corruption in the power of special
interests
and they want health care period
they want to stop worrying about it they
want to know that their families are
covered
and they know in their hearts what
democrats
have kept pointing out every time
republicans have had the opportunity to
strip away the health care protections
of hardworking americans
republicans have done that that is a
fact
and no matter whether you're a mom
suffering through cancer
a dad who survived a heart attack a
young kid struggling with asthma
republicans will not rest until they rip
away the protections that ensure you can
still afford your health care we have
never
stopped talking about health care and
now with polls closed across the
continental u.s
we can protect what the american people
have once again determined that they
need us to protect especially in the
middle of a pandemic
they want the party of health care to
represent them
the democratic party that's their
firewall against the recklessness
of washington republicans and it's an
awesome responsibility
but the american people have put the
right party in charge of their house
with prescription drug costs through the
roof house democrats passed the elijah
cummings
lower drug cost now act with corruption
running rampant in donald trump's
washington
house democrats passed the most
comprehensive anti-corruption
legislation in a generation
and with the need to jump start our
economy and rebuild our nation while we
raise american wages
house democrats passed the moving
forward act
house democrats have never stopped
working for the people and with a deadly
pandemic
taking close to a quarter million
american lives
while grinding our economy to a halt
house democrats are up to the challenge
we face tomorrow and for many years to
come that's what people here in moline
expect from us
and deserve from us they want us to live
by the same values that people here
teach their kids
decency respect hard work
and an appreciation for for folks who
may not look like you
or your family these are the values
that represent our best selves as both a
party
and as a country when we remember them
when we remember the people from places
like moline we win
the whole country wins so let us be
grateful for the opportunity placed
before us tonight as lawmakers
but let's also be humble there are
millions of ballots
left to count and so much damage
left for us to undo our path
to the america we all believe in is in
our grasp now
it's right in front of us right outside
our front door
speaker pelosi thank you for your
leadership
for never losing sight of how best to
use your awesome power as speaker
for families for children and for a
better future
it really is an incredible honor to be
able to serve alongside you
thank you all and good night thank you
madam chair it is my
honor to serve with you and we all both
share the honor
of serving with our most diverse and
dynamic
caucus most diverse in the history
of any country including our own
starting with our own
so now with this victory we will proceed
uh to prepare for the transition
we will talk about what we've talked
about all along as
madam chair referenced for the people we
will lower health care costs by lowering
the cost of prescription drugs
and protecting the pre-existing medical
condition as well as others from the
assaults that the republicans continue
to make on them
at the present time in the court of
the supreme court of the united states
for the people we will increase
paychecks by building the infrastructure
of america in a green and resilient way
creating jobs and opportunity not only
for jobs
but for equity for ownership of
companies that participate
in all of that with uh workforce
development
educationally to train a young people
on to uh not only aspire to that
profession
but perhaps to some ownership and for
the people we
will we will uh talk about
a cleaner government with hr1 which we
will pass
on the floor of the house on the very
first day
of the new congress madam chair
referenced the elijah cummings hr-3 our
bill to lower the cost of prescription
drugs
and also to by enabling us to negotiate
uh with uh for the secretary of hhs to
negotiate for lower prices
i want to reference in hr1 are john
lewis
ending voter suppression legislation
that is so
important and as you've seen so needed
in this campaign so madam chair as you
had suggested
it's not over until every vote is
counted and there are plenty more votes
to count in fact
we haven't even started in my state of
california the whole west coast
and beyond and uh again we look forward
to
coming together in our
democratic majority in the congress of
the united states
that success would not be possible
without your leadership
thank you madam chair sherry bustos
thank you all good evening
or anyone on his campaign